la grande soirée des [ __ ] sur france
2 dans une quinzaine de minutes le
concert au zénith une cinquantaine
d'artistes avec en meneuse de revue
muriel robin qui est notre invité mais
d'abord place aux images quelques temps
forts de ce spectacle exceptionnel
non
tu m'etonnes
ça va
non
m
ma
maintenant regardez l'émission se dit
surprise mais voilà bonsoir vous est la
marraine de cette soirée et vous êtes
meneuse de revue de cette cinquantaine
d'artistes soirée unique exceptionnel
quelle est la marque de fabrique de ce
zénith 98 écouter une marque de fabrique
est là tous les ans mais qui est là à
chaque fois plus forte
c'est vraiment une soirée magique pour
nous et je suis sûr pour les gens qui
vont la regarder il ya effectivement une
cinquantaine d'artistes les mêmes des
nouveaux on l'a vu quand on a une
mireille mathieu fait je veux pas qu'on
les découvrir je crois vraiment qu en
hiver quand on l'attend tous nous les
artistes cette soirée avec impatience je
crois je le ressens tout cas quand on
l'a fait les artistes viennent avec le
meilleur d'eux mêmes les seuls le reste
aux vestiaires il ya quelque chose qui
se passe qui est absolument unique
il faut regarder cette émission il faut
la regarder parce que vous ferez partie
d'une chaîne de solidarité qui commence
par les en me lavant qui ont besoin des
restos du coeur qui passe en tout cas
pour ce soir par nous il faut la
regarder parce que ça peut être envie
d'acheter les vidéos et que ça reviendra
sur un repas elle est dernière cette
soirée en tout cas les vidéos ont
engrangé 18 millions de français
beaucoup de repasser 10 % du budget
total de de l'association les restos du
coeur voilà et en quoi l'esprit de
coluche est toujours présent dans cette
manifestation qui est ce soit en tout
cas un immense divertissement coûté si
on doit mettre un nom sur l'esprit de
coluche je n'ai pas pensé mais il est
question d'humanité de solidarité de
coeur sont les restos du coeur et comme
je vous le disais les gens à ce moment
là laisse parler cette chose-là m ca
devant voilà donc donc il faut aller on
va et c'est comment dire
c'est vraiment quelque chose mais
vraiment ces gens j'en ai encore
l'émotion ce que c'est vraiment quelque
chose de fort qui se passe et qui va
aller jusqu'au gens j'en suis sûr c'est
un moment vraiment unique
on vous sent très militante pour ça je
veux bien l'être ce n'est pas ma nature
mais pour ça oui
alors sans dévoiler toute la soirée
quand même quelques moments forts
quelques surprises au delà des moments
forts du lac cette année là on
s'améliore d'année en année on a
toujours peur je me dis toujours comment
la prochaine va pas être aussi beau
l'année dernière j'avais un souvenir
formidable c'est encore au dessus cette
année parce qu'on a fait une mise en
scène on a des les artistes sont en
costume alors ça permet de voir du lac
ou
oublie son costume dont il joue un peu
la comédie cabrel devient gagman et un
garçon très drôle moi je l'avais jamais
vu comme ça et on a effectivement des
gens nouveaux d'été d'un décor et les
artistes reviennent plus souvent tout au
long de l'émission c'est à dire une fois
qu'on les a vus on les revoit aux
comptes les missions et les moments de
comédie
donc ils sont très drôles et voilà ça
fait une soirée encore une fois unique
fort qu'il faut regarder pour pour un
moment de solidarité bien sûr et de
bonheur j'en suis sûr aussi vous allez
nous surprendre vous même j'espère en
quoi aux comptes mails et des avions ont
marié avec un truc à plumes donc marié
un peu bizarre mais je la soirée va
surprendre parce qu'elle est vraiment
différente
je remercie maurienne aura compris